hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
in this video i'm going to be talking
about something very important for
property investors specifically if you
are
buying houses or controlling houses that
are hmos this is about how are the
utility prices that are going up right
now gas electric everything's going up
how is that going to affect hmos i've
got i've got a lot to say on this topic
but i'm going to keep this super brief
because i'm kind of annoyed at all the
nonsense that i'm hearing on social
media because this is what the narrative
is at the moment everyone's saying
oh utility prices are going up
how are people going to afford to do
rent to hmo anymore because if you're if
your business model is renting a house
breaking it up room by room and then
renting it out on a room by room basis
and that's how you get paid you have to
pay the bills because part of the
service for the new tenants is that
you're paying the bills and if bills are
going up
then it's going to eat out of your
profit hmos aren't very profitable
anymore hmos are going to die rent to
hmo's dead that is the most moronic
ridiculously
flawed thing i've ever heard let me
explain why in this video okay a few
reasons number one this is this is the
stupidity of it
because if something goes up in price
right like for instance if petrol goes
up if petrol goes up in price okay do
you go oh my gosh how are the petrol
stations going to afford to make profit
because it's more expensive for them to
get petrol but what do they do they just
put the price of a petrol right if wood
goes up timber has gone up a lot the
last few years the price of timber
to get timber is expensive not just for
us but for the for the people that
supply the wood
so if if the cost of wood goes up what
happens
they just put the cost of wood up
and in the same way if you've got a
property and you're renting it out and
you're including the bills
you're renting a room out and as part of
the service you're including the utility
bills
and utility bills go up what are you
gonna do
you're just gonna put the price of the
room rent up
i don't see what the big deal is
it's absolutely crazy in fact let me
prove what i'm saying
if you go on spare room dot co dot uk
right now spare room dot co uk is a
website where people advertise their
room if you look in any city you go to
liverpool manchester birmingham london
edinburgh right and you type in rooms
available in such-and-such a city okay
if you do that in a spare room
room rents have gone through the roof in
the last
six months
a year ago the average room was about
400 pounds
you know i i know because i've got loads
of hmos
the average room rent was you know maybe
400 pound a month now do it go to spare
room code uk and just look at how much
people are demanding for the price of a
room rental
it's like five to six hundred pounds per
month even in cities like freaking
stoke-on-trent where you can buy houses
for 60 grand and they're charging like
500 sometimes even 600 pounds a month go
on spare room and look at rooms wanted
and see how much people are prepared to
pay for a room five six hundred pounds a
month even in cheap dump hole cities so
what's happening is as cost of living
and as utility prices are going up
people that are providing a room
with utilities included are just
increasing their room rents
so
no people with hmos are not going to be
screwed people who do rent to hmos are
not going to be screwed in fact let me
explain something even more interesting
we are entering right now into a
recession recession is when people don't
have money they're struggling
financially a recession is either the
banks run out of money they stop lending
the people run out of money or fear of
one of the above
so right now people are tight
financially we're entering into every
session
when people can't afford things
when people are struggling financially
what do they do i'll tell you what they
do
they downsize
right if you're in an apartment or a
house and you're struggling to pay the
rent which people are right now because
rents are going up like crazy house
prices are going up utility prices are
going up everything's going up apart
from wages what's staying the same these
people what do they do
they go oh man maybe i'll rent a room
instead
so in recessions in tough times
prices for rooms go up in value now you
some people in the comments right now
are going to say oh that's really bad
you're exploiting the situation no this
is called supply and demand
every business has a willing buyer and a
willing seller you will charge for rooms
this is why i love capitalism so much
people say it's not right that people
own houses and rent them out
those people that say that are morons
what's the what's the other
option that the government own all the
houses
and if the government own all the houses
we still have to pay rent to the
government
how much rent do we pay whatever they
demand with capitalism and with
landlords and with recessions and with
what i'm talking about which is buying
houses individual landlords you can't
charge whatever you want you can only
charge what people are prepared to pay
and if you're charging too much someone
else will undercut you
it's a free market it's a fair market so
if you if you're one of those people
that say oh samuel you're exploiting the
the housing crisis you're a [ __ ]
because we're not exploiting the housing
crisis we are providing what people want
namely affordable accommodation
so what do i think about the utility
prices
i haven't got an opinion on it
but i'll tell you something factual it's
going to make people want to rent rooms
more so instead of buying a house
renting it out you're much better off to
buy a house and rent it out
room by room
pay the utilities once on the house
and then charge five people for the
utilities and they'll pay a premium
because they know how expensive
utilities are and because people will be
queuing up for your rooms
because they can't afford to rent a
whole house
and pay for the bills on top so they'll
be desperate to rent rooms they'll need
rooms and you will ethically give them
what they want which is rooms that's how
you make money in property that's what's
going to happen with the utility prices
going up that's how it's going to affect
hmos and that's how it is and has
affected hmos just go spare room
[Music]